Transcriptor: Federica Bruno
Revisor: Larisa Esteche
Cuando le platiqué a mi familia mis
intereses por estudiar artes, mi mamá
le dijo a mi hermana que le prometiera
que no me iba a dejar morir de hambre.
Mi hermana es 5 años menor que yo.
Me titulé en Sistemas Computacionales
y mi familia fue muy feliz.
Yo no lo sabía.
Conseguí un trabajo y seguía dudando.
Ahorraba dinero para poder viajar,
pero nunca tuve el tiempo.
Ahora no tengo el dinero y de alguna
manera viajo más que cuando lo tenía.
Tomé un curso de arte los fines de semana
y me preguntaba por qué no podía
dedicarme solo a eso.
En ese momento me di cuenta que el arte
para mí no era un hobby y que mi felicidad
se encuentra en
cosas menos habituales.
Tenía que tomar una decisión, continuar
con mi trabajo o seguir mis deseos
por convertirme en un artista profesional.
Un buen día, a los 26 años,
tomé esa decisión.
Renuncié a mi trabajo, renuncié a la
estabilidad económica que me daba, a mi
posgrado en tecnologías y a usar traje
sastre de tres piezas de lunes a viernes.
Salí del corporativo con mis cosas
en una caja de cartón y sin mi credencial
colgando del saco.
Mi familia, que siempre me ha apoyado,
me seguía preguntando cosas.
Si después de estos estudios de todos
modos regresaría a trabajar.
Y es que a pesar de su apoyo, que siempre
lo he tenido, desde la primera vez que
les mencioné mis intereses por estudiar
artes, me decían ¿Por qué no tomas un
curso de verano o te dedicas a ello los
fines de semana y lo tomas como un hobby?
En ese momento me di cuenta
de la importancia del arte en la vida,
en mi vida.
Este nuevo viaje incluía
no solo cambiar de ciudad.
El golpe más duro fue psicológico, fue
enfrentarme a la brecha generacional
con mis compañeros en todos
los salones de la universidad.
Siempre hay un señor.
Ahora me tocó a mí ser el señor.
Todos, absolutamente todos, tenemos una
canción favorita, un libro, una película,
una obra de arte, quizá sin la que no
pudiéramos entender una etapa de nuestra
vida o explicar una emoción en estos
tiempos complejos de pandemia.
Volví a esa reflexión.
Las personas que nos dedicamos a la
creación es común que pasemos el mínimo
contacto con el mundo durante períodos
de horas, meses, días, semanas.
Incluso hay quienes pagamos por ello.
Se llaman residencias de artistas.
Ahora, en el confinamiento fueron
obligatorias y el pago no fue monetario.
Fue emocional durante las primeras
semanas de encierro.
Me encontraba trabajando como lo hacía
normalmente en la casa, pero me di cuenta
de que algo no era habitual.
El miedo y la angustia que muchos
sentíamos me hizo buscar estos espacios
en las cosas que le daban
sentido a mis días.
Volví a leer textos, a escuchar música,
a ver mi película favorita dos o tres
veces a la semana, sin tener culpa
del tiempo.
Perdón.
Y fue reflexionando en esta tranquilidad
que pensé en un mundo sin arte.
Imaginen las reuniones con los compañeros,
con nuestros amigos,
sin música, los viajes sin museos.
Comer palomitas sin ver una película.
Son los momentos de crisis los que nos
hacen buscar estos espacios
de tranquilidad emocional.
Yo tuve esta crisis a los 26.
Bueno, la primera.
Históricamente la creatividad
nos ha mantenido vivos.
Es la creatividad por la que empezamos
a taparnos del frío.
Descubrimos el fuego.
Construimos refugios y herramientas
cada vez más modernas.
Inventamos lenguajes, entre ellos el arte.
Este 2020 nos hizo regresar a ese instinto
de supervivencia, a reconocer
nuestros sentimientos en el arte.
México es el segundo país
en el mundo con más museos.
Existen 1177 museos
y 56 por ciento de ellos
son gratuitos.
Durante el 2018,
según cifras del INEGI,
hubo 57.7 millones de visitantes
y muchos de estos museos
incorporaron visitas
virtuales durante la pandemia.
Mi familia y yo estamos más tranquilos.
Hemos aprendido mucho del arte y sabemos
que es una profesión como sistemas
computacionales, que requiere dedicación,
esfuerzo y tiempo.
Mi mamá y mi hermana están más tranquilas,
saben que estoy seguro estudiando artes,
siendo un artista profesional
y que no voy a morir de hambre.
Gracias.